[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 134 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Hello, Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: How are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK:
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm vaguely
awake, but I'm getting there.
MELANIE WARRICK: Why
are you vaguely awake?
MARK MANDEL: So I just
got back from Unity Hack
Week in Denmark.
I had a really great time with
the Unity team over there.
And possibly not so
strangely enough,
today's episode is talking
about the new strategic alliance
between Unity and Google Cloud.
So we'll be talking
about connected games
with Unity and Google Cloud.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, that's awesome.
It's convenient that
you were over there,
and that we're now
also talking about it.
So, Mark, also happy 4th.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
Fourth of July.
[FIREWORKS SOUNDS]
MELANIE WARRICK: Which I
know you don't celebrate.
MARK MANDEL: No,
being Australian.
But good for everyone who's
in America and is listening.
MELANIE WARRICK: For
all the other people who
might be celebrating today and
seeing fireworks, as usual,
tonight and maybe
eating hot dogs.
So yeah, that's why
you're releasing
this episode this
week, Mark, because--
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
MELANIE WARRICK: --you
don't celebrate Fourth.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
That's fine.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's fine.
Well, so this week, Mark,
who we are talking to?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so this week, we're
going to be talking to Brett
Bibby, VP of engineering
at Unity Technologies,
and we'll also
be talking to Micah Baker,
who is the product manager
at Google Cloud for games.
MELANIE WARRICK: Awesome.
As always, we start out with
the cool things of the week,
and we end with the
question of the week.
And this week's
question is, how do I
report errors to Stackdriver
from a Cloud Function?
MARK MANDEL: That's an
excellent question, Melanie.
I'm glad you asked.
MELANIE WARRICK: I think
it's a great question.
I didn't even come up with it.
It's amazing.
All right, so the cool
things of the week.
So for all of the listeners out
there who might be watching,
I don't know, the
World Cup right now,
we have a blog post to start
off our cool things of the week
from Felipe Haffa, who's
one of our colleagues.
And hopefully one day
soon we will have him
back on the podcast.
But he did a blog post that
is basically doing a World Cup
visualization.
He shows all the goals so far.
And so he literally
has on here and he
explains how he uses some of the
different Google Cloud Platform
tools and to build the
visualization, his data
acquisition, how he
extracted the goal data.
He's got code in here.
And using Data Studio
to create the sheet.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
You should check it out.
MARK MANDEL: We
should check it out.
So after that, I
want to bring up
a blog post that came out
on the Google Cloud Platform
blog called, why we
believe in an open cloud.
Want to be accurate.
I think it's a really
important article.
It's by--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Melody Meckfessel.
MARK MANDEL: Melody
Meckfessel, Eric Brewer,
so vice presidents
of Google Cloud,
Miles Ward, director
of solution architects
Google Cloud, Sarah Novotny,
open source strategy lead,
Google Cloud.
MELANIE WARRICK: Which all of
these people we've actually
spoken to with the
exception of Melody.
And we actually are going
to be interviewing--
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
MELANIE WARRICK: --her at Next.
MARK MANDEL: That is true.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So that's coming.
MARK MANDEL: That is coming.
It's essentially
an outline of why
we believe in an
open cloud, what
do we mean by an open
cloud, sort of open
is the power to pick
up an app and move it.
Open source software
permits a richness
of thought and continuous
feedback loop with users.
We talk about some
of the open source
projects we work, why these
things are important to us.
It's worth reading
and just being aware
of exactly how Google Cloud
is trying to position itself
with the open cloud.
I think it's really
worth a good purview.
MELANIE WARRICK: I agree.
It's definitely
worth a good purview.
So we also this week
have Kubernetes 1.11,
a look from inside Google.
So, Mark, are you
excited about this?
MARK MANDEL: So this is
also a really great article.
It's a perspective of the
most recent Kubernetes release
that's come out about what
parts of Kubernetes 1.10,
or 1.11 I should say, had
influence from Google and what
parts of Kubernetes
is Google working
on and they're committed to.
So there's some things
in here for our changes
to custom resource definitions,
cloud provider plug-ins.
There's also a really
interesting bit in this
where it's talking about new
features not built in 1.11,
which I think is
kind of amusing.
But they're also
talking about some
of the governance
things they're doing,
and some of the software
engineering orchestration,
if you want, and how they're
helping define that process
internally as well.
They talk a little
about customize
as well, a few other
things like that.
So if you ever sort of
sat back and been like,
I wonder what specifically
Google works on on Kubernetes,
this can actually be
quite enlightening.
There's another
really great article
as well from the CRE team.
Actually, there's two
of them, but we'll
mention them together,
part one and a part two.
The CRE articles are
always fantastic.
They're talking about
understanding error budget
overspend.
So basically, it's a
discussion about what
happens if you have an
error budget, right,
so you have the amount of stuff
that basically you can mess up
during a given time period, and
what happens when you actually
run out of your error budget,
and then you end up going over.
What happens, and what are the
reasons why that might happen,
and what to do
when that happens,
because maybe there is a reason.
Maybe there is just something
you have to get in there
and it ends up breaking more
things or that kind of stuff.
It's a pretty interesting read.
I really like the SRE
and the CRE articles.
I think they're always
super, super interesting.
And there's a part
two that is good
housekeeping for error budgets.
So basically, error
budgets aren't something
you just fire and forget.
They're an ongoing sort of
living document, if you will.
So you can talk
about how to adjust
as you need to as time goes on.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
I think the last
thing we were going
to mention for this week is that
there's a new GitHub repo using
Firebase to add cloud-based
features to games built
on Unity.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
This is also great.
Shout out to Dane Liergaard.
He's also done some work on the
[INAUDIBLE] project as well.
He's a DPE at Cloud,
all around nice person.
He's been working on a project
for Firebase Unity solutions.
And the first one
coming out on that
is basically a
Firebase-based leaderboard,
talking about, showing
you, and giving you
code about how you can set
up a leaderboard on Unity
using Firebase.
And it has a really cute little
flaming icon driving in a car.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
It is actually really cute.
It's a nice little image.
Mark, I think it's time to
go and talk to the folks
from Unity.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go do that.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
MARK MANDEL: So
I'm here in Denmark
with two wonderful people.
I'm here with Brett Bibby, VP of
engineering Unity Technologies,
and Micah Baker, product
manager at Google Cloud Games,
all to talk about
Unity and Google Cloud.
How are you both doing today?
BRETT BIBBY: Doing great.
Thanks for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
We had a recent announcement
talking about Unity and Google
Cloud that I'm very
excited about, possibly not
surprisingly.
But before we do that, why don't
we have a chat with both of you
about who you are
and what do you do?
BRETT BIBBY: Sure.
I'm Brett Bibby.
I'm head of R&D at
Unity leading the team
of more than 500 talented women
and men where the core Unity
engine and platform is built.
MICAH BAKER: Sure.
I'm a product manager
with Google Cloud,
and so I have the opportunity to
help drive the strategy for how
the Cloud can actually support
the gaming developers, which
is something I'm quite
passionate about.
Because the more
I can help them,
the better the games will be
that I can play that they make.
So we're excited about
all the opportunities
between Google Cloud and Unity.
MARK MANDEL: For
those people who
may not be familiar
with Unity, Brett,
do you want to tell us a
little bit about what Unity is?
BRETT BIBBY: Well, the
easiest description
is Unity is the world's
leading game engine.
But it's really a platform
for building real time
interactive experiences that
run on more than 30 platforms.
Its success, though,
I think is the key,
like why does it exist?
And it's just Unity
allows rapid development
using an extensible editor and
gets you onto the platforms
that you need to be successful.
And that's really
the secret sauce.
Been that way for a decade.
And with the diversity and
explosion in devices and OSes
and the complicated
things around that,
it just turns out that it's
a useful way to do that.
And we help make people
be successful with that.
MELANIE WARRICK: So, Mark,
you alluded to the fact
that there was an announcement.
What was the announcement?
MICAH BAKER: Oh,
I can take that.
So we got to announce
a strategic alliance
between Unity Technologies
and Google Cloud
to work on making
the development
of connected games faster and
easier for our developers.
BRETT BIBBY: For
Unity, it means that we
can enable a whole new
generation of games
and experiences that
don't exist today.
Unity has many creators
on its platforms.
And this new alliance
will unlock a variety
of new innovative experiences.
We're only successful when
our users are successful,
so this opens up a huge,
brand new, blue ocean
frontier of possibilities.
MICAH BAKER: And you know, I
get this question a lot, though,
what is a connected game?
It might be good for us
to, for our audience,
to define what we mean
by connected game.
It might be straightforward
for some people,
but just to be clear, what
we mean by connected game
is games that are kind
of dynamic and living
where the developer
can update the content.
Could be a single
person game, or it
could be a multi-person game.
And in the case of the
multiplayer type games,
they could be connected
by the developer
and also by other players.
MELANIE WARRICK: So you were
talking about the developer
tools that we are working
as an alliance together with
and how we're doing
connected games.
What are some of the
tools that are being used?
BRETT BIBBY: The way I think
of it is I kind of think
of it in three parts.
I mean, first, at
the core level,
you've got to have some
sort of networking.
And this doesn't matter
whatever you're trying to build,
if it's connected in
some way, eventually
you're going to have to
send some information
over some sort of network.
And what's interesting
in games is
we actually identified three
critical core architectures
that are used in games.
So for example, you have some
things that are like, you know,
multiplayer,
land-based experiences
where a group of players are
running around and interacting
with each other.
And that needs
one set of things.
Those might be server
authoritative, for example.
You have other kinds
of games like RTSes,
where you need lock step.
In this frame, this
is what I'm doing,
and this is what you're doing.
And you have others that are
twitch, like fighting games,
where I'm going to punch you,
you're going to punch me.
But then, we're going
to have to figure out
a few frames later
what actually happened,
roll back, roll forward,
this kind of thing.
Now most networking solutions
try to solve this all in one.
And what we've decided is that's
actually not the right way
to do it.
Instead of being jack of all
trades, we need to split up.
So just at the core
level, it's really
about implementing these three
networking architectures that,
really, out of the box,
not only perform well,
but they're set up
in a way that makes
these kinds of
experiences easy to build,
which means the code,
everything else on top
of that is easy to build.
Now, that's just a
foundational piece.
And the next thing you
need is you actually
need to build an
experience on top of this.
And Unity and Google
are going to make
that super seamless to not only
build, but deploy your game.
And we demonstrated this
last week at Unite Berlin.
And I almost think it got a
little lost in the fanfare.
People didn't really
know what they saw.
But what we showed was
the strategic alliance
between Google
and Unity is going
to make that super seamless
to go from developing
on my local machine, working and
play testing in a small group,
and then spilling
over into the Cloud.
And then when I'm actually
ready to launch and live
operate this game,
that's going to be
a huge change in the
number of players
that are going to come in.
And what we demonstrated
at Unite Berlin was
there's no difference
between these.
We can seamlessly scale
from a local machine
to a small cloud experience
connecting our testers together
to then a huge
number of players.
And we showed 1.5
million player capacity,
more than 60,000
servers being spun up
in less than three minutes.
So that's crazy.
That's something that
hasn't been possible before.
And Google plus Unity
are uniquely positioned
to actually solve that.
MARK MANDEL: So this
sounds pretty amazing.
Micah, what does this mean for
Google Cloud Platform, though?
MICAH BAKER: Well, so
one of the great things
about this strategic alliance
is that Unity already
provides a leading
solution for developers
to work on their game vision.
They have a big dream of
what they want to build,
but they don't want
to have to mess
with all the complexity
of the tooling
and worrying about all the
platforms and so forth.
So Unity does this great job of
democratizing game development.
And what Google Cloud is
bringing to this picture
is democratizing access to
the cloud infrastructure.
So while Unity could develop
a whole bunch of things
on their own, they're going
to be able to do it faster
by collaborating
with Google Cloud
to do the infrastructure work,
which is our core expertise.
And so combined, we're going
to produce managed services
for these same developers to
do these one-click deployments
of multiplayer games
straight into the cloud.
So all these things will
run on Google Cloud,
but the developers won't
have to know what that means.
They won't have to know, what
is that product I'm using?
They just need to know, I
got this scaled up globally,
and it runs my game,
and I'm not going
to be a victim of my
success, which is a danger.
Maybe it's very popular
when your game launches,
and your infrastructure crumbles
because it wasn't actually
planned well.
We'll make sure that
that's always planned well.
BRETT BIBBY: And
this is a super--
I mean, just building on that,
that's a super hard problem
to solve.
I mean, I don't know that it's
actually been solved before.
People have solved
individual pieces
and optimized for
themselves on it.
Even the most experienced
game developers in the world
have suffered from day one
outages or peak issues.
And so I think Google's ability
to seamlessly scale and Unity's
ability to build the
front end experience,
it is a pretty
interesting combination
when you put it together.
MARK MANDEL: Micah,
does this mean
that Unity developers
are going to get access
to specific Google
Cloud products?
Or do we have any plans on
what that might look like?
MICAH BAKER: Yeah, it's
an interesting question.
Because we really want
to walk this line of not
adding complexity
to the development
environment and process.
But we do want to provide
access to innovative Cloud
technologies that could actually
enable new types of gameplay.
For example, we have a
product called Cloud Spanner,
which enables a global
relational database
for any developer.
But if I just said,
hey, developer, here's
Cloud Spanner, they
wouldn't necessarily
know what that even means.
But if I said, hey, do you want
a global relational database
for game save data or game
state data or player data,
they're going to
know what that means.
So what we will be
doing is offering
these kind of prepackaged
solutions to the developers
through the Unity
package manager,
and they're going to be able to
access the solution that they
want without having to
worry about which product
or products are actually doing
the work behind the scenes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Can you talk more
about the plans for the future
of this strategic alliance?
You were talking a little
bit about the infrastructure,
the core tools that
you're sharing.
What the next steps look like.
BRETT BIBBY: Well,
the next steps
are, obviously, getting
our two groups together.
And we're doing that
here at a Hack Week,
already starting
the steps on that.
I think, Mark, you've
got a project that's
starting those early steps that
you can talk about where we're
munging some stuff
together and just
really understanding
and coming together,
like the sets of
problems we solve,
the sets of problems
Google solves,
and how we can do that
effectively together.
But I think we do
have a long range
vision of it's just seamless.
It's stepwise.
It's easy for people to adopt.
They know what
they're going to get.
They can put those
blocks together
and focus on actually
building great experiences
and not worrying about
the other bits and pieces.
So I'd say in the
short term, it's
understanding the
landscape of all the things
that we need to do.
In the long term vision is
that it's just dead simple
to start, build, deploy,
and run your experiences.
And that's what
we're committed to.
And we're going to do
whatever it takes between here
and there to get there.
MARK MANDEL: And Brett, it's
also worth noting I think,
you're moving all your core
infrastructure to Google Cloud
Platform as well?
BRETT BIBBY: That's right.
You know, it's funny.
I mean, Unity is
founded by people
from three different
countries here in Denmark.
And our first employee
was located in Iceland,
our second was in Germany,
our third was in Lithuania.
So from day one, we've been
sort of a connected company.
And we built all of that
just, as many others have,
on just the G Suite,
the Google Platform.
And we've been using
all of your applications
for more than a decade.
And along the way,
we've also started
using it for various other
Cloud services that you offer.
And we're super excited to
move all of our infrastructure
over to the Google tech, because
we've had nothing but success,
and it's what we know.
And it's sort of, I think,
when we look at the stuff,
it implements things and
approaches things in a way
that we get and that
is, I think, accessible.
We have this saying at Unity,
accessible yet uncompromising.
It's really easy to get into.
But then when you need
to go deep, it's there.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And the question I
keep getting is, well,
when I'm here at Hack
Week, which is lovely,
if I'm a Unity developer,
what does this migration mean
for me?
What am I getting out of this?
MICAH BAKER: So if
you're a Unity developer,
and you want to think about
the infrastructure migration,
you really should think
about your infrastructure
that you use, and Unity will
perform as well or better
than it did before.
But it should be kind of
transparent to the Unity
developer.
But it also means that
the future services
that Unity launches will be
launching on Google Cloud,
and we'll help with the
architecting of that
and getting those optimized
to run on Google Cloud.
That also includes things
like our recently announced
open source matchmaking
project, which
will be not only launched
as an open source project,
but also become a managed
service on the Unity platform
so that a developer
could easily integrate
a matchmaker into their
game without having
to know how to build an entire
matchmaker from scratch.
We're just getting started with
these multiplayer technologies,
and there will be
more services to come.
And they'll all be
built on Google Cloud.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark,
you were talking about how
you guys are at Hack Week.
What are some of the
particularly awesome things
you've been seeing
hacked on at Hack Week?
MARK MANDEL: So it's
been pretty good.
I've been working on a
project with a group of Unity
employees.
There's a bunch of us working
on taking an existing demo
and turning it into
a multiplayer demo.
So I've been working with the
teams that are working on some
of the multiplayer stuff.
We're hacking on some new
things, some things that
are coming, and just trying to
mung all the things together.
It's been really exciting.
But I've seen people
with VR helmets on.
And I've seen people
with, I don't know,
it looks like network
gear floating around.
Brett, I'm sure you've seen
a whole bunch of stuff here.
You've been practically
running this thing.
Haven't you?
BRETT BIBBY: Yes.
And what's funny is that
I'm always surprised.
I mean, this will be our
13th or 14th Hack Week,
and I'm always--
I saw one of our senior
graphics engineers
with a sewing machine late
into the night the other night.
So obviously, there's some
surprise waiting for us.
But they've built some
sort of AR experience
that uses clothing props
and every other thing you
can imagine.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Tell us a bit of the
background on Hack Week.
What's this all about?
BRETT BIBBY: We have more than
500 talented women and men
building the core Unity
product, and we're
distributed across the globe.
We're actually located
in more than 30 cities,
about 19 countries.
And functionally, it's a chance
for us to gather in one place
once a year.
But it's actually
much more than that.
Most of the innovations
and breakthroughs
we have brought to
the Unity product
have actually come
out of Hack Weeks.
Why?
Well, it's actually because you
mix a diverse set of people,
diverse set of skills,
domain knowledge,
all collaborating in one place,
and you simmer it on high
for a week and magic happens.
So this is great.
And this year, we
have a special guest.
So we have Google with us
this year, which is fantastic.
And we're also joined by
almost 50 women engineers
from around the world as part of
our Women in Gaming initiative.
And they're hacking
alongside of this as well.
So it's just great the crazy
mix of people and the diversity
that we're getting.
It's actually magical.
MARK MANDEL: Well, thank you
very much for inviting us.
I've been having a
really good time.
BRETT BIBBY: I guess
we should ask you.
I mean, we kind of
reversed the question,
I guess, but like, what
do you think of Hack Week?
I mean, I've only actually
ever been at a Unity
internal Hack Week.
I mean, like, what
do you make of it?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I've been having a ball.
It's been really fun.
I've had some
experience previously
a little bit with Unity.
But it's been really
great to get--
I mean, I only know like
a little part of it.
And so it's been really great to
get the different perspectives
and see how, basically, the
people who live in the trenches
with this stuff, how
they build things.
And also, just everyone's
really lovely, which is great.
It's been an absolute
pleasure hanging out here.
I mean, where we are
physically is gorgeous,
so can't complain too much.
MICAH BAKER: Yeah.
It's a fantastic setting.
I'm also really impressed at
the ambitions of the people
here at Hack Week.
And when you look at the
different projects they're
taking on, people are not
going for just something
I could do in my sleep.
They're going for hard
problems, and it's things
that they're not
currently working on.
So I think it's really
focused on the right things
to generate those
innovations that only come
from getting away from
your normal routines
and getting with
new people, and you
get a whole different dynamic.
MARK MANDEL: I love the
fact, as well, we got told,
if you're here, and
I know you're here
with all your teams, but
meetings are optional.
I wish I had meetings
are optional weeks.
That'd be great.
BRETT BIBBY: Well, the
irony there is, of course,
I'm the one that
said that, right?
And then I had a meeting,
and everybody showed up just
to say, I'm not
coming to this meeting
because it was optional.
So it's fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK: It
sounds like a good time.
And I like how you just
turned the tables on Mark
with the question.
So anything else
that you guys wanted
to cover around our
strategic alliance in terms
of where things
are at with Unity,
with GCP, with the Hack Week?
MICAH BAKER: I mean, there's
a lot of feedback coming in.
There's lots of resources I
guess we could talk about.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Let's talk about resources.
MICAH BAKER: There's
currently a blog
posting that you can look
at on blogs@Unity3D.com,
which is currently taking
questions and responding
to things.
So if people are
interested, definitely
suggest heading
over to Unity3D.com
and looking around at the
connected games information.
BRETT BIBBY: So we have
the privilege actually of--
because of our
success, we are also
early in the labs with people.
We have pretty
good view of what's
happening in the next year,
two years, three years.
And I like, you know, you
take where you are today,
where you think you're
going to be in two years,
and then you also look
out 10, 15, 20 years.
And you can kind of get a pretty
good bearing on what's what.
And if you think
about it, could you
imagine 20 years from
now or 30 years from now
not having some
form of connectivity
when experiencing content?
I mean, it doesn't
mean that everything's
going to be a massive
multiplayer game
or anything like that.
But it's a certainty
that everything
is becoming more
and more connected,
and that there's value in that.
And from a gameplay
perspective, we
know that content is the most
expensive way to build value.
And in the old days, it was
kind of like, well, we're just
going to throw 30 levels,
50 levels, 100 levels,
and if you wanted to, say, do a
bunch of different mini games,
there's a huge amount of
engineering cost in doing that.
So what we had to do
is make that content.
But as we move from standard
definition, high definition,
ultra high definition, the
scene complexity is growing,
we need something else,
and we need some way
to augment that gameplay.
And fortunately for
us, human beings
make pretty good artificial
intelligence for games.
And so when you
mix humans together
collaborating or competing
in online environments,
when you bring dynamic
elements to stuff,
you're able to create a very
live dynamic experience that
is super engaging.
And I think-- so connected
games is so crucial.
Getting out and going to
learn about this stuff
is really critical for
people's success going forward.
MELANIE WARRICK: Brett, I'm glad
you mentioned about content,
because I've noticed more and
more the media is becoming more
merged, media like film,
television, and concepts
are getting more and
more merged in gaming.
Do you see that
continuing to be,
these spaces that really
merge together, especially
as the technology
continues to advance?
BRETT BIBBY: Right.
Well, in terms of
merging together,
there's a lot of different
viewpoints on this.
I think that when
I imagine playing
a game in my living room
in augmented reality, yeah,
that's pretty cool.
Do I like the idea
of walking down
the street in augmented reality
and living in something that's
marked up by other people?
You know, it sounds
kind of interesting,
but I think that I'm not
sure that the world is
ready for complete immersion.
I think that's what's driving
it towards the content itself.
I think making the
content more alive,
the behavior behind the content
is really, really critical.
But I don't know that the
mixing, the mash up of content
is something that's ready for
the prime time out in the world
today.
MARK MANDEL: Micah,
if people want
to hear more about the open
source matchmaker or things
like that, are there places
they could go as well?
MICAH BAKER: Yeah.
Actually, I'd love
to give a shout out
for one of the great
sources for keeping up
with this kind of content
and getting more information
about what we talked about.
Unity3D.com/connectedgames
is the landing page for Unity
to explain what do we mean by
connected games with a lot more
detail, what's coming with the
managed version of the open
source matchmaker, and more.
MARK MANDEL: And if people want
to learn about the open source
side of things?
MICAH BAKER: We'll be
making that open source
project public this summer.
It's actually very
soon now, trademark.
And we're really excited to
get that out there for people
to download, test, and
hopefully contribute code back.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Is there anything
else we managed
to miss anything,
other than saying,
we're having a lovely time, and
thank you for having us here?
BRETT BIBBY: We're
having a lovely time.
The weather's amazing.
So in Denmark, the weather can
change at a moment's notice,
so we should end here and
get outside while we can.
MARK MANDEL: I think I'm going
to go to the beach actually.
MICAH BAKER: It's
just right over there.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That sounds lovely.
Well, you guys have fun.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Brett, Micah, thank
you so much for joining us
on the podcast today.
BRETT BIBBY: Thanks, Mark.
MICAH BAKER: Thanks
for having us
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Micah, Brett, thank you
so much for joining us today.
It's great to hang out
with you in person,
and it was great to
chat with both of you
about Unity and Google Cloud.
But why don't we get stuck
into our question of the week?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
and this week's question
is, how do I report
errors to Stackdriver
from a Cloud Function?
MARK MANDEL: So this is
pretty straightforward,
which is kind of nice.
You're just going to
need to know where it is.
You can essentially emit an
error from a Cloud Function
to Stackdriver Error
Reporting by simply--
I love things that say simply--
by simply logging an
error object to a console.
So basically,
console.error, and then
passing in the error message.
It's really that simple.
It may not necessarily
be something
that's immediately
picked up if you
want to get the specific
details of an error.
So doing it this way
is important inside
like your try
catches, and basically
how you handle your errors
inside of your Node.js type
applications.
Well, inside your Cloud
Functions at least.
It's worth noting that
the following will not
emit a Stackdriver error--
throwing something that's not
an error object, for
example, logging an error
object at the info level,
logging something that's
not an error per se either,
and that kind of stuff.
So make sure you use
console.error, and then pass
in your error message, and
you should be good to go.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
And they have a nice
little bit here too
that talks about how if you're
not sure it's an error object,
that they show you basically
how you can check it.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark,
now that you're back,
where are you going next?
MARK MANDEL: Where
am I going next?
I think I'm going to Next next.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
You like what I did there?
MELANIE WARRICK: I did.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: I did
set that up for you.
MARK MANDEL: [INAUDIBLE] that.
Yeah, jokes are better
when you explain them.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
you're speaking at Next.
And we will be at Next as well
doing a number of interviews.
We'll be talking to a number
of folks that are there.
You should come by and see us.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Prior to that, I'm
actually going to be
doing a couple of talks,
which I will share next week.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: And yeah,
we'll share some links on that
as well.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
I think you're
bouncing around a lot.
MELANIE WARRICK: Potentially.
MARK MANDEL: Potentially.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Melanie, thank
you for joining me
for yet another
episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]